T-15 seconds. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedad. T-1910. 9 or 8? On January 28, 1986, the Challenger spacecraft blasted off from Cape Canaveral. Two, one, and liftoff. Liftoff saw the 25th space shuttle mission and it has cleared the tower. Seconds after lift-off into a clear blue sky, something went wrong. Flight controllers are looking very carefully at the situation.
倒计时15秒。这里是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。倒计时1910。9还是8？1986年1月28日，挑战者号航天飞机从卡纳维拉尔角发射升空。二，一，点火升空。升空，这是第25次航天飞机任务，它已经飞离发射塔。在升入晴朗蓝天后的几秒钟内，出了问题。飞行控制人员正在非常仔细地观察局势。
Obviously a major malfunction. It was much more than a malfunction. It was a disaster. As millions of people watched in horror, trails of smoke and debris flew off in different directions. We have a report from the flight dynamics officer that the vehicle has exploded. The space shuttle blew up. Those words flashing across America today. The challenger exploded this morning just after liftoff from Cape Canaveral, the crew of 7 now presumed it. Navarro, the crew of 7 now presumed it. After the explosion, NASA officials were hauled to Capitol Hill and put to questioning. Who finally made that decision to go?
显然发生了重大故障。这不仅仅是故障，这是一场灾难。数百万人在惊恐中目睹了这一幕，烟雾和碎片向四面八方飞散。我们从飞行动态官员那里得到报告，航天飞机已经爆炸。航天飞机爆炸了。今天这些话在全美闪现。挑战者号今天早上在卡纳维拉尔角升空后不久爆炸，机上7名机组人员目前被推定遇难。爆炸发生后，美国国家航空航天局（NASA）的官员被传唤到国会山接受质询。到底是谁最终做出了发射的决定？
What was the chain? How did that link? What happened then specifically? Members of Congress asked the tough questions. How could this have happened? Who's to blame? These are the kinds of questions we have when any catastrophe occurs, whether a spacecraft has exploded, a new war has broken out, or the world is swept up in a fast-moving
链条是什么？环节是如何连接的？当时具体发生了什么？国会议员们提出了尖锐的问题。这怎么可能发生？谁该负责？无论航天飞机是否爆炸、新战争是否爆发，还是世界是否被快速蔓延的灾难所席卷，当任何灾难发生时，我们都会产生这类疑问。
pandemic. In all these cases we want to know, who screwed up? Your government failed you. Those entrusted with protecting you, failed you. And I failed you. We ask, who knew what? When? The State Department had received repeated warnings that the situation was getting worse.
大流行病。在所有这些情况下，我们都想知道，是谁搞砸了？政府辜负了你们。那些受托保护你们的人辜负了你们。我也辜负了你们。我们问，谁知道什么？什么时候知道的？国务院曾多次收到警告，称局势正在恶化。
And we try to figure out how... How do we make sure that this kind of breach... That such an accident... ...does not ever happen again. ...with many of these incidents, there's a sense that they could have been avoided. That someone knew something, but didn't say anything.
我们试图弄清楚如何……我们如何确保这种违规……这种事故……永远不会再发生。……在许多此类事件中，人们有一种感觉，即它们本可以避免。有人知道一些事情，但什么也没说。
Or if they said it, they weren't believed. Or if they were believed, nothing was done. This week on Hidden Brain, we revisit a favorite 2019 episode about the psychology of warnings and how we can all become better at predicting the future. Why some warnings get heard, why many are ignored, and the pitfalls of being a prophet. We begin the tale of warnings made and warnings ignored in the middle of Alaska. It's a balmy day, barely jacket weather.
或者如果他们说了，也没人相信。或者如果他们被相信了，却什么也没做。本周在《隐藏的大脑》节目中，我们重温2019年一期关于警告心理学的热门节目，探讨我们如何才能更好地预测未来。为什么有些警告会被听到，为什么许多警告被忽视，以及作为先知的陷阱。我们从阿拉斯加中部关于警告被发出和被忽视的故事开始。那是一个温暖的日子，几乎不需要穿外套。
I'm in a car riding on a weather-beating road that leads out of Fairbanks. Chris Heimstra is driving and he points out something. You can see in the road here, you see all these bumps and all these curves. These aren't your standard potholes. The state of the road is a sign of something far more significant. Beneath the pavement, the ground is disintegrating. What lies below the asphalt is the Alaskan permafrost, and it's melting. Permafrost is any soil or ice or rock that's frozen for more than two years, like two consecutive years.
我正坐在一辆车里，行驶在费尔班克斯外一条饱经风霜的道路上。克里斯·海姆斯特拉（Chris Heimstra）正在开车，他指出了某样东西。你可以看到路上的这些颠簸和曲线。这些不是普通的坑洼。路况是某种更重要事物的迹象。在路面之下，地面正在解体。沥青下面是阿拉斯加的永久冻土，它正在融化。永久冻土是指任何冻结超过两年，比如连续两年冻结的土壤、冰或岩石。
Picture the plants and animals that lived in Alaska over the past tens of thousands of years. After they died and fell to the ground, they froze. Pumifrost is made up of layer upon layer of this organic frozen material. There's a place where you can see what's happening deep inside this pomephrost. It's a tunnel that's hundreds of feet long. It's built into the side of an Alaskan hill. Chris is a research scientist at the Army Corps of Engineers. He works in the cold regions research and engineering laboratory out of Fairbanks.
想象一下过去几万年来生活在阿拉斯加的动植物。它们死后落到地上，就冻结了。永久冻土是由一层又一层这种有机冻结物质组成的。有一个地方你可以看到这种永久冻土深处正在发生什么。那是一条几百英尺长的隧道。它建在阿拉斯加一座山的山腰上。克里斯是美国陆军工程兵团的研究科学家。他在费尔班克斯的寒区研究与工程实验室工作。
He has spent a lot of time in this tunnel and he's taking me there today to show me something important. There is 40,000 years of earth history that's stored and frozen in time. To get to that frozen history we walk through a set of gates over to a wood cabin, a whole bunch of hard hats. We head over to what looks like a nondescript wooden shed. It has a sign on the outside that says US Army Corps of Engineers and a warning to watch your step. Inside, it's pitch black. At the far end, there's another door that leads into the actual tunnel. Chris turns on the lights and leads me through.
他在这个隧道里花了很多时间，今天他带我来这里是为了向我展示一些重要的东西。这里储存着4万年的地球历史，并被冻结在时间里。为了到达那段被冻结的历史，我们穿过一道大门，来到一个木屋，那里有一堆安全帽。我们走向一个看起来不起眼的木棚。外面有一个牌子，写着“美国陆军工程兵团”，并警告要小心脚下。里面漆黑一片。在尽头，有另一扇门通向真正的隧道。克里斯打开灯，带我穿过。
We walk down to a lower area. The deeper we go, the lower down you go into the tunnel, the older you are in sediment. The further back we move in time. Okay, so like back over here, when Chris describes what's in the tunnel, he's even toned. But what I can see all around me is completely extraordinary. So on that, that's like a 43,000 year old piece of, probably willow, that's been sitting down here for quite a while.
我们走到一个较低的区域。我们走得越深，进入隧道越低，沉积物就越古老。我们在时间上回溯得越远。好吧，就像这边，当克里斯描述隧道里的东西时，他的语气很平淡。但我周围所能看到的一切都非常非凡。所以那个，那是一块大约43000年前的，可能是柳树的碎片，它在这里已经待了很长一段时间了。
43,000 years old. It actually looks like it could have fallen last year. It's amazing the cold temperatures and how long it can be organic matter can be preserved here. If you're picturing this like a real life trip on the Magic School bus, you're right. Except there's one part of the experience that doesn't exactly fill me with wonder. I think the aromas, one thing that people notice right away, I was just going to ask you, is it just me or does this place sting? It's suddenly got an unusual smell and that's your organic matter that's coming back into the atmosphere. All around me, the decaying plants and animals smell like food gone bad in a freezer.
43000年了。它看起来就像是去年才掉下来的。低温以及有机物质能在这里保存这么久，真是令人惊叹。如果你把这想象成现实生活中的《神奇校车》之旅，你是对的。除了体验中有一个部分并不能完全让我感到惊奇。我想是气味，人们注意到的第一件事，我正要问你，是只有我这样觉得，还是这个地方很刺鼻？它突然有一种不寻常的气味，那是你的有机物质正在回到大气中。我周围，腐烂的动植物闻起来就像冰箱里变质的食物。
The smell is unpleasant, but what it ought to be is terrifying. Something is happening here that has consequences for the entire planet. The organic matter trapped in the pomephrast, fungi, plants, animals, it's towing. As a thaw, it decays, and as it decays, it releases extraordinary amounts of carbon into the atmosphere. How much carbon, scientists say the amount of carbon that's stored in the pomephrast, is about double of what's in the entire atmosphere. Let me say it again. Double. It's in the deep freeze. What happens if that temperature goes up, or for some reason it thaws a little bit more, what happens at that carbon? A place you don't
气味令人不快，但它本该是令人恐惧的。这里正在发生的事情对整个地球都有影响。困在永久冻土中的有机物质，真菌、植物、动物，正在解冻。随着解冻，它们会腐烂，而腐烂时，它们会向大气中释放大量的碳。释放多少碳？科学家说，永久冻土中储存的碳量大约是整个大气中碳量的两倍。让我再说一遍。两倍。它处于深度冷冻状态。如果温度升高，或者由于某种原因它融化得更多，那些碳会发生什么？一个你不想让它去的地方
necessarily want it is back in the atmosphere. We don't want it back in the atmosphere because carbon dioxide contributes to climate change. But a vicious cycle has already started. As the planet warms, the permafrost thaws, all those dead animals and plants and fungi start to decompose. More decomposition means more carbon released into the atmosphere, which means warmer temperatures, which means even more melting in the permaphrost. What follows is disaster. The firestorm in Australia has burned in area
就是回到大气中。我们不希望它回到大气中，因为二氧化碳会导致气候变化。但一个恶性循环已经开始。随着地球变暖，永久冻土融化，所有那些死去的动植物和真菌开始分解。分解越多，释放到大气中的碳就越多，这意味着温度更高，这意味着永久冻土融化得更多。随之而来的是灾难。澳大利亚的火灾烧毁的面积
as large as West Virginia. So it started raining and no big deal. And then we see the water going down the street start to get a little bit higher. At the rate, global temperatures are rising 60% of all the glaciers here in Xinjiang. Nearly 11,000 glaciers will be gone within 50 years. Chris doesn't need to turn on the news to see what rising temperatures are doing to the planet.
和西弗吉尼亚州一样大。然后开始下雨，没什么大不了的。然后我们看到街上的水开始变高了一点。按照全球气温上升的速度，新疆60%的冰川。近11000座冰川将在50年内消失。克里斯不需要打开新闻就能看到气温上升对地球的影响。
When he's in the tunnel, he can see it right in front of his eyes. He can smell it. He's reminded of it every time he drives on the cracked pavement. And there's a feeling that he can't escape. It comes when he's at work, when he talks to strangers, even when he's in the comfort of his own car. That feeling is futility. He can see a catastrophe unfolding in front of him,
当他在隧道里时，他能亲眼看到。他能闻到。每次他开车经过破裂的路面时，他都会想起这一点。有一种他无法逃避的感觉。这种感觉在他工作时、与陌生人交谈时，甚至在他舒适的车里时都会出现。那种感觉是徒劳。他能看到一场灾难在他面前展开，
but no one seems to be listening. Or people seem to be worried about the wrong things, like in a conversation he had earlier in the day. The claim was made that most of the CO2 in the atmosphere comes from volcanoes, which isn't the case. Who made the claim? It was somebody on the school field trip earlier today. And I pushed back against that politely.
但似乎没有人听。或者人们似乎在担心错误的事情，就像他当天早些时候的一次谈话中那样。有人声称大气中大部分二氧化碳来自火山，事实并非如此。是谁提出的这个说法？是今天早些时候学校实地考察时的一个人。我礼貌地反驳了这一点。
It's hard because you gotta be really, it's so hard to be, you don't wanna offend people, you don't wanna, because making someone angry isn't gonna change your mind at all. So you gotta be really careful about how you wait into things and you don't know this person necessarily and there's not a familial tie.
这很难，因为你必须非常，这太难了，你不想冒犯别人，你不想，因为让别人生气根本不会改变他们的想法。所以你必须非常小心你如何介入事情，而且你不一定认识这个人，也没有亲属关系。
All we have really in common is that our kids go to the same school and they're in the same class. But it was a crucial piece of misinformation that wasn't true, and then you just say flat out, that's not true. That's going to shut everything down, and it's not going to help me in any way. It's just going to make somebody who thinks I'm a jerk. To Chris, it seems as if the pushback he gets is driven by a logic contempt that some people feel towards science and scientists.
我们真正共同点只是我们的孩子在同一所学校，在同一个班级。但这是一个关键的错误信息，事实并非如此，然后你只是直截了当地说，那不是真的。这会把一切都搞砸，对我没有任何帮助。这只会让别人觉得我是一个混蛋。对克里斯来说，他得到的反击似乎是由一些人对科学和科学家感到的逻辑蔑视所驱动的。
Like it's not relegated or limited to your work. It's a critique of you as a person as if you're just trying to lie to people about the work you do, which doesn't make any sense. I mean, your stock as a scientist is because of your honesty. If you're not honest as a scientist, your career is over. And it should be over. Chris feels invisible. He walks in a remote place, 40 feet below the surface,
就像它不仅限于你的工作。这是对你个人的批评，好像你只是试图对你所做的工作撒谎，这根本说不通。我的意思是，你作为科学家的价值在于你的诚实。如果你作为科学家不诚实，你的职业生涯就结束了。而且它应该结束。克里斯感到自己被忽视了。他在一个偏远的地方行走，在地下40英尺处，
in a part of the country that's unfamiliar to most Americans. A lot of them will never make it up here. A lot of them won't go into the Permphrost tunnel. A lot of them won't go run up above the tunnel or throughout Alaska where Permphrost exists or even understand what it looks like, what it smells like. So how do you communicate that? How do you say like there's a value and you understanding what you don't currently understand? How do you get people to see that there's value in understanding what they don't understand? Chris's question is an ancient question. For millennia, we often shunned and shamed people who have warned us of looming disaster. Why does this happen? Why do human beings who care about their survival ignore warnings of doom?
在这个国家的大部分美国人都不熟悉的地方。他们中的许多人永远不会到这里来。他们中的许多人不会进入永久冻土隧道。他们中的许多人不会跑到隧道上方或整个阿拉斯加存在永久冻土的地方，甚至不了解它看起来是什么样，闻起来是什么样。那么你如何沟通呢？你如何说，理解你目前不理解的东西是有价值的？你如何让人们看到理解他们不理解的东西是有价值的？克里斯的问题是一个古老的问题。几千年来，我们经常回避和羞辱那些警告我们灾难即将来临的人。为什么会这样？为什么关心自己生存的人类会忽视末日的警告？
When we come back, we are going to do something unusual. We are going to look for answers to that question, not in science, but in literature. We are going to dive into Greek mythology and talk about a doomed prophet. The lessons from her story still resonate today. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In Greek mythology, the gods loom large, so large that many of them fill our imaginations even today, Zeus with his thunderbolts, Aphrodite the goddess of love, Hades in charge of the underworld, Athena goddess of wisdom.
当我们回来时，我们将做一些不寻常的事情。我们将寻找那个问题的答案，不是在科学中，而是在文学中。我们将深入研究希腊神话，谈论一位注定失败的先知。她故事中的教训在今天仍然引起共鸣。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在希腊神话中，众神显得非常高大，以至于即使在今天，他们中的许多人仍然充斥着我们的想象力，宙斯和他的雷电，爱神阿佛洛狄忒，掌管冥界的哈迪斯，智慧女神雅典娜。
The gods of ancient Greece moved among humans, some of those humans were themselves touched with divine powers. One of the most striking was the Prophet Cassandra. Cassandra remained so memorable that her story has inspired movies, television, even campy pop music. In 1982, the Swedish band Abba dedicated a song to her more than 2,500 years after she was first memorialized by Homer, Eskilis, and Euripides. This power that Cassandra had was incredible. Except, there was one problem. No one believed her. It's not Cassandra's fault that she's not believed.
古希腊的神灵在人类中穿行，其中一些人类自己也被赋予了神力。最引人注目的是先知卡珊德拉（Cassandra）。卡珊德拉令人难忘，以至于她的故事激发了电影、电视，甚至俗气的流行音乐。1982年，瑞典乐队ABBA为她写了一首歌，距离她最初被荷马、埃斯库罗斯和欧里庇得斯纪念已经过去了2500多年。卡珊德拉拥有的这种力量是不可思议的。只是，有一个问题。没有人相信她。不被相信并不是卡珊德拉的错。
This is Emily Wilson. I'm a professor of classical studies at the University of Pennsylvania. Emily is going to take us back to the legend of the Kingdom of Troy. She's going to help us understand what this ancient myth still has to teach us. Cassandra's father, Pryam, was the king of Troy. It's safe to say that Cassandra didn't suffer from only child syndrome. Pryam has, according to different accounts, either 50 or 100 children. She's one of the many children of Pryam.
这是艾米丽·威尔逊（Emily Wilson）。我是宾夕法尼亚大学古典研究教授。艾米丽将带我们回到特洛伊王国的传说。她将帮助我们理解这个古老的神话今天还能教给我们什么。卡珊德拉的父亲普里阿摩斯（Pryam）是特洛伊国王。可以肯定地说，卡珊德拉并没有患上独生子女综合症。根据不同的记载，普里阿摩斯有50或100个孩子。她是普里阿摩斯的众多孩子之一。
Cassandra has a blessing that is really a curse. She can see the future, but no one will believe her. But even if you set aside the curse, it turns out she also did several things that made it less likely she would be believed. For one thing, her prophecies were a pick. When she revealed her visions, she spoke in language that was a little hard to understand. Let the mob endlessly gorging on this clan, raise a shriek over the sacrifice on which stones
卡珊德拉有一个祝福，实际上是一个诅咒。她能看到未来，但没有人会相信她。但即使你抛开诅咒，事实证明她也做了几件事，使她更不可能被相信。首先，她的预言是隐晦的。当她揭示她的愿景时，她使用的语言有点难以理解。“让暴民无休止地吞噬这个家族，为祭品发出尖叫，石头
will fall in their turn. She speaks primarily in symbols and metaphors that she can foresee the ox killed at the altar. She can foresee blood and slaughter. She doesn't speak in a way that spells out exactly as soon as I walk into this house, Clayton Nesteros is going to take the axe and hack us both to death. Because that's not the way oracles speak. She speaks in prophetic language. Cassandra's best known prophecy had to do with one of the world's most famous carpentry
将轮流落下。”她主要用象征和隐喻说话，她能预见祭坛上被杀的牛。她能预见鲜血和屠杀。她说话的方式并没有明确指出“我一走进这所房子，克莱顿·内斯特罗斯（Clayton Nesteros）就会拿起斧头把我们俩都砍死”。因为神谕不是这样说话的。她用预言性的语言说话。卡珊德拉最著名的预言与世界上最著名的木工项目之一有关，
projects, the Trojan horse. There's a war between the Trojans and the Greeks and it's dragging on. It keeps going for 10 years without decisive victory on either side. The turning point comes when the Greeks have an idea. That they should build a great big wooden horse and have their best warriors on the Greek side hide inside the wooden horse. They leave the great big wooden horse outside the walls of Troy. As the Trojans watch from their city, the Greeks get in their ships, seemingly in defeat, and sail away. Their mysterious gift remains on the beach, and the Trojan's debate whether
特洛伊木马。特洛伊人和希腊人之间有一场战争，而且拖延了很久。它持续了10年，双方都没有决定性的胜利。转折点出现在希腊人有一个主意的时候。他们应该建造一匹巨大的木马，让希腊方面最优秀的战士躲在木马里。他们把那匹巨大的木马留在特洛伊城墙外。当特洛伊人从城里观看时，希腊人登上他们的船，似乎战败了，扬帆远去。他们神秘的礼物留在海滩上，特洛伊人争论是否
to throw up in the city gates and bring in the horse. Is this some kind of gift for the gods? Is it a holy offering? Should we mistrust it? Should we not mistrust it? Cassandra knows that this gift is not a gift at all. She tells her fellow citizens not to open the gates of Troy. In her own convoluted way, she says, this is a terrible idea. Don't do it.
要打开城门把马带进来。这是给神的某种礼物吗？这是一个神圣的祭品吗？我们应该不信任它吗？我们不应该不信任它吗？卡珊德拉知道这份礼物根本不是礼物。她告诉她的同胞不要打开特洛伊的城门。用她自己复杂的方式，她说，这是一个糟糕的主意。不要这样做。
But she doesn't have any real power. Her fellow children don't recognize her as a prophet. And so she's not taken seriously. The consequences are disastrous. The childrens decide in the end to bring the horse in, and then, of course, in the middle of the night, the Greek warriors spring out of the horse and start slaughtering the citizens inside the city.
但她没有任何真正的权力。她的同胞并不承认她是先知。所以她没有被认真对待。后果是灾难性的。特洛伊人最终决定把马带进来，然后，当然，在深夜，希腊战士从马里跳出来，开始屠杀城里的公民。
You think that after Cassandra accurately predicts the fall of Troy, some people might start believing her. You'd be wrong. She makes another prediction that fails to gain any traction. As the city is burning and the women of Troy are forced to board Greek ships as slaves, all the prisoners are distraught, all except Cassandra, who seems weirdly happy. Her mother seems deeply concerned about her, worried for her, as one would be for a daughter who keeps saying crazy stuff, and who also seems to have this perverse idea that being taken into slavery could be a good thing.
你以为在卡珊德拉准确预测特洛伊陷落后，有些人可能会开始相信她。你错了。她又做了一个预测，但没有引起任何反响。当城市在燃烧，特洛伊妇女被迫作为奴隶登上希腊船只时，所有的囚犯都心烦意乱，除了卡珊德拉，她看起来奇怪地高兴。她的母亲似乎对她深感担忧，为她担心，就像人们会为一个不断说疯话的女儿担心一样，而且她似乎还有一种变态的想法，认为被带走做奴隶可能是一件好事。
There's a reason why Cassandra has this oddly positive reaction. Whereas everyone else can only see what's right in front of them, she can see two steps ahead. She already knows something about her situation. She knows she's going to die, but so is her captor, the Greek general Agamemnon. Revenge is coming, even if it means her own death. Cassandra sees a gleam of hope in the fact that she knows Agamemnon's going to be murdered horribly. She can see that there's going to be bad things for the Greeks down the line. So, to recap, there are several things besides the curse that make Cassandra less likely to be believed. She speaks in cryptic language, doesn't have any formal authority, and is too far ahead of everyone else.
卡珊德拉有这种奇怪的积极反应是有原因的。当其他人只能看到眼前的东西时，她能看到两步之外。她已经知道关于她处境的一些事情。她知道她会死，但她的俘虏，希腊将军阿伽门农（Agamemnon）也会死。复仇即将来临，即使这意味着她自己的死亡。卡珊德拉在知道阿伽门农将被残忍谋杀的事实中看到了一线希望。她能看到希腊人未来会有坏事发生。所以，总结一下，除了诅咒之外，还有几件事使卡珊德拉不太可能被相信。她用隐晦的语言说话，没有任何正式的权威，而且比其他人领先太多。
There's one more thing. She asks too much of the people she warns. This happens when Agamemnon takes Cassandra back to Greece with him as a slave. They go to his home. Agamemnon doesn't know that during his absence, his wife, Clytemnestra, has started an affair. He doesn't know that Clytemnestra is not pleased to have him back, but she pretends to be happy. So she welcomes him into the house, along with Cassandra as his human property. He goes first into the house and then Cassandra pauses to give these prophecies, these riddling prophecies. Cassandra foresees his death and her own.
还有一件事。她对她警告的人要求太多。这发生在阿伽门农把卡珊德拉作为奴隶带回希腊时。他们去了他的家。阿伽门农不知道在他离开期间，他的妻子克吕泰涅斯特拉（Clytemnestra）已经开始了一段婚外情。他不知道克吕泰涅斯特拉并不高兴他回来，但她假装很高兴。所以她欢迎他进屋，连同作为他人类财产的卡珊德拉。他先走进屋子，然后卡珊德拉停下来给出这些预言，这些谜语般的预言。卡珊德拉预见了他们的死亡和她自己的死亡。
Look at this! Look! Keep the bull away from the heifer! She's caught him in her dress, her engine on her black horn, striking! Into the basin, he falls, with the water lies. He met his death in the bath. It's lay and wait for him, I tell you. Or, to translate, Clayton Nestres about to hack her husband to death with an axe. For Agamemnon to take a Sandra seriously, he would have to see that his life was in danger, that his wife despised him, that far from being a victorious warrior, he was walking into a death trap.
“看这个！看！让公牛远离小母牛！她用她的裙子抓住了他，她的引擎在她的黑角上，打击！他掉进了盆里，水躺着。他在浴缸里遇到了他的死亡。我告诉你，这是为他设下的埋伏。”或者，翻译过来，克莱顿·内斯特罗斯（Clayton Nestres）即将用斧头把她的丈夫砍死。为了让阿伽门农认真对待卡珊德拉，他必须看到他的生命处于危险之中，他的妻子鄙视他，他远非一个胜利的战士，他正走进一个死亡陷阱。
To save his own life, he would have to change his entire outlook. He wants to think of himself as a strong triumphant city-saccer and he's only going to process the information that confirms that belief about himself and he's going to ignore all the signs both from Clyde and Nesterah and from Cassandra that might suggest that reality is not the only reality and in fact you're missing a whole lot of information here. Things play out just as Cassandra that might suggest that reality is not the only reality and in fact you're missing a whole lot of information here. Things play out, Justice Cassandra predicted. She's caught him in her dress, her engine on her black horn, striking.
为了挽救自己的生命，他必须改变他整个观点。他想把自己看作一个强大的胜利的城市征服者，他只会处理那些证实他对自己这种信念的信息，他会忽略所有来自克莱德和内斯特拉（Clyde and Nesterah）以及卡珊德拉的迹象，这些迹象可能表明现实不是唯一的现实，事实上你错过了很多信息。事情的发展正如卡珊德拉所预测的那样。她用她的裙子抓住了他，她的引擎在她的黑角上，打击。
Clitam Nestra gives him a lovely bath and she entraps him in a net as well in order to make sure that if he struggles, after the first blow, he won't get away, so she strikes him multiple times till he's good and dead and also hats Cassandra to death. The soundtrack it was a particularly gruesome murder, but maybe I'm wrong, maybe this is part for the course in Athenian tragedy. I think it's part for the course, I mean,
克吕泰涅斯特拉给了他一个可爱的洗澡，她也用网困住了他，以确保如果他挣扎，在第一击之后，他不会逃脱，所以她多次打击他，直到他死透，也把卡珊德拉砍死了。配乐，这是一场特别可怕的谋杀，但也许我错了，也许这是雅典悲剧中的常态。我认为这是常态，我的意思是，
it's much less gruesome than the death of Pentheus, say, yes. That was usually some gory death, yeah. Why else would you go to the theater? Now of course, Cassandra was cursed. By definition, it didn't matter how persuasive she was. She was never going to be believed. But her failed attempts to warn those around her
它比彭透斯（Pentheus）的死要少一些可怕，是的。那通常是一些血腥的死亡，是的。不然你为什么要去看戏呢？当然，卡珊德拉被诅咒了。根据定义，她有多有说服力并不重要。她永远不会被相信。但她警告周围人的失败尝试
can give us insights into how warnings are heard, whether they're taken seriously, and when they're acted upon. So what does an effective Cassandra sound like? I speak loudly all the time, because I'm kind of aggressive person, you know, even though I'm all, I'll be 70 next year. My wife said, will you please calm down? She's been saying it for 43 years now, and it hasn't happened. The actual name of this Cassandra is Andrew Nazios. His moment of prophecy involved a life
可以让我们深入了解警告是如何被听到的，它们是否被认真对待，以及何时被采取行动。那么一个有效的卡珊德拉听起来是什么样的？我一直大声说话，因为我是一个有点咄咄逼人的人，你知道，即使我，我明年就70岁了。我妻子说，你能冷静点吗？她已经说了43年了，但这并没有发生。这个卡珊德拉的真名是安德鲁·纳齐奥斯（Andrew Nazios）。他的预言时刻涉及到一个
and death choice that affected hundreds of thousands of people. Before we get to that, we need to understand the formative moments in Andrew's career. In many ways, he was an unlikely hero. In the 1980s, he served in the Massachusetts House of Representatives. At a Republican National Committee meeting in 1988, he didn't exactly get the star treatment. Chair recognizes Nassio from Maryland. Massachusetts. Nassio from Massachusetts.
影响数十万人的生死抉择。在那之前，我们需要了解安德鲁职业生涯中的形成性时刻。在许多方面，他是一个不太可能的英雄。在20世纪80年代，他在马萨诸塞州众议院任职。在1988年的一次共和党全国委员会会议上，他并没有得到明星待遇。“主席承认来自马里兰州的纳齐奥。马萨诸塞州。来自马萨诸塞州的纳齐奥。”
Nassio, I'm quarantined here, sorry. Before he got to his Cassandra moment, Andrew was brought into salvage a boondoggle of a transportation project in Boston. The big dig. It redirected a massive highway into a tunnel under the city. Andrew came in several years into the project. At that point, it was a mess, with huge cost overruns. Andrew had two things going for him.
“纳齐奥，我被隔离在这里，抱歉。”在他到达他的卡珊德拉时刻之前，安德鲁被请来挽救波士顿一个交通项目的烂摊子。大挖掘（The Big Dig）。它把一条巨大的高速公路改道到一个城市下的隧道里。安德鲁在项目进行了几年后加入。那时，它是一团糟，成本严重超支。安德鲁有两件事对他有利。
He had experienced leading big institutions, and he had his temperament. I'm sort of a type A personality, very kind of aggressive and a dominant figure in any institution that I run. So I could get the institution to do what I wanted it to do, what I thought was right to do. He was, in fact, able to figure out why the project's finances were out of whack.
他有领导大型机构的经验，而且他有他的气质。“我是一个A型人格，在任何我经营的机构中都是一个非常咄咄逼人且占主导地位的人物。所以我能让机构做我想让它做的事，我认为正确的事。”事实上，他能够弄清楚为什么项目的财务状况失控。
But his efforts weren't always appreciated. It was the most difficult year of my career. Actually, I actually felt safer in Sudan and Iraq and Afghanistan that I did in Boston. One person threatened to break my neck while I was investigating the big dig. Andrew had spent much of his career overseas. His experience leading several national and international organizations, Coffee Eye of President George W. Bush, who appointed him to lead USAID. That's the agency responsible for America's involvement in international development.
但他的努力并不总是受到赞赏。“这是我职业生涯中最困难的一年。实际上，我在苏丹、伊拉克和阿富汗比在波士顿感觉更安全。当我在调查大挖掘时，有人威胁要打断我的脖子。”安德鲁在海外度过了他职业生涯的大部分时间。他领导多个国家和国际组织的经验，乔治·W·布什总统的咖啡眼（Coffee Eye），他任命他领导美国国际开发署（USAID）。那是负责美国参与国际发展的机构。
It's here that Andrew had his Cassandra moment. In 2003, Andrew briefed top members of the Bush administration about escalating violence in Sudan. By that point, marauders were charging into villages, setting them on fire, sending civilians fleeing. They were known as a janguede. They quickly took over a vast and dusty region on the edge of the Sahara. Darfur. Andrew's warnings and advice had an impact.
正是在这里，安德鲁有了他的卡珊德拉时刻。2003年，安德鲁向布什政府的高层成员简要介绍了苏丹不断升级的暴力事件。到那时，掠夺者正在冲进村庄，放火焚烧，导致平民逃离。他们被称为“金戈威德”（Janguede）。他们迅速占领了撒哈拉边缘一个广阔而尘土飞扬的地区。达尔富尔。安德鲁的警告和建议产生了影响。
The US supplied billions of dollars in aid to Sudan over the next several years. Inspired the economic difficulties, our aid will continue to flow. President Bush also put political pressure on Sudanese leaders. Some of his measures were behind the scenes, others more public. The news media began to take note. Today President Bush announced tough new economic sanctions against Sudan over the continued persecution of the minority population in Darfur. Andrews actions at USAID have become a case study on effective warnings. That's according to
美国在接下来的几年里向苏丹提供了数十亿美元的援助。“尽管经济困难，我们的援助将继续流动。”布什总统也对苏丹领导人施加了政治压力。他的一些措施是在幕后的，另一些则更公开。新闻媒体开始注意到。“今天布什总统宣布对苏丹实施严厉的新经济制裁，因为其在达尔富尔继续迫害少数民族人口。”安德鲁在美国国际开发署的行动已成为有效警告的案例研究。这是根据
Christoph Mayer. I'm a professor of European and international politics at Kingscovich, London. Christoph has spent many years studying how warnings are made and which ones manage to break through the noise. He says there are several reasons Andrew Nazio's managed to persuade the Bush administration to act. One is he was able to show how further escalation with many hundreds of thousands of people that was highly likely and he was able to put that into a presentation, you know, chart the escalation of the conflict into the future. Andrew commissioned a study that predicted how many people would die if the US didn't intervene. He also got US spy satellites to take pictures of Darfur.
克里斯托弗·迈耶（Christoph Mayer）所说。我是伦敦国王学院欧洲和国际政治教授。克里斯托弗花了很多年研究警告是如何发出的，以及哪些警告成功突破了噪音。他说安德鲁·纳齐奥斯成功说服布什政府采取行动有几个原因。一是由于他能够展示进一步升级将导致数十万人死亡，这是极有可能的，他能够将其放入一个演示文稿中，你知道，绘制冲突未来升级的图表。安德鲁委托进行了一项研究，预测如果美国不干预会有多少人死亡。他还让美国间谍卫星拍摄达尔富尔的照片。
To photograph the ground every day to show the villages that were being burned from day to day. And these photographs were so clear that the photographs were unimpeachable in terms of their quality, in terms of what the atrocities were and they weren't 30 at 100 villages. They displaced two million people. So Andrew laid out clear evidence. There was something else that helped him make the case to the president. He was an insider. Was I taken seriously yes because I had a relationship with the president? That's presidents plural. He had campaigned twice
每天拍摄地面照片，以显示每天被烧毁的村庄。这些照片非常清晰，以至于照片在质量方面、在暴行方面是无可挑剔的，而且它们不是30个或100个村庄。它们导致200万人流离失所。所以安德鲁提出了明确的证据。还有其他事情帮助他向总统陈述了理由。他是内部人士。“我被认真对待了吗？是的，因为我和总统有关系。”那是复数的总统。他曾两次为
for George H. W. Bush and he had worked on the George W. Bush campaign in 2000. He was not seen as one of these, you know, do-gooders, one of these kind of liberal NGO types. Yes, he had a history in the NGO sector. He was an expert, but he was also a kind of conservative pedigree. He had experience in the armed forces. He was seen as someone who understood that the president's time was precious and understood the preferences and he was seen as kind of part of us. Besides his political credentials, Andrew was also an insider in another way. He was a Christian who'd spent years leading an international Christian NGO.
乔治·H·W·布什竞选，他曾在2000年乔治·W·布什的竞选活动中工作。他没有被视为这些，你知道，好心人，这些自由派非政府组织类型的人之一。是的，他在非政府组织部门有历史。他是一位专家，但他也有某种保守的血统。他在武装部队有经验。他被视为一个了解总统的时间很宝贵，了解偏好的人，他被视为我们的一员。除了他的政治资历，安德鲁在另一方面也是内部人士。他是一位基督徒，曾花多年时间领导一个国际基督教非政府组织。
He knew that George W. Bush's identity as a Christian was important to him and important to his re-election chances in 2004. Christoph Mayer says Andrew laid out the political consequences of inaction in Darfur, where many of the civilians being attacked were Christian. He was able then to show how that kind of escalation would be politically relevant to the Bush administration at the time, how it would impact on the re-election chances, and how it would connect to Christian constituency in the US, which of course are one of the supporting constituencies of the Bush administration because it was
他知道乔治·W·布什作为基督徒的身份对他很重要，对他2004年的连任机会也很重要。克里斯托弗·迈耶说，安德鲁阐述了在达尔富尔不采取行动的政治后果，那里许多受到攻击的平民是基督徒。他能够展示这种升级在当时对布什政府的政治相关性，它将如何影响连任机会，以及它将如何与美国的基督教选民联系起来，这当然是布什政府的支持选民之一，因为
also Christians who were in Sudan were largely affected by this violence. Andrew implicitly understood a widespread psychological bias. We all tend to look more sympathetically at suffering when the people who are suffering have something in common with us. There's another part to this. Andrew was successful because he didn't ask President Bush to make a major U-turn. From the very beginning of his administration, the president had been interested in what was happening in Sudan. The first presidential review that the president ordered was on Sudan policy. Now what came to be known as a genocide in Darfur did claim hundreds of thousands of lives. So it may be hard to see Andrews warning as effective. And yet if Andrew had not acted, Christophe says he believes things would have turned out worse.
苏丹的基督徒也主要受到这种暴力的影响。安德鲁隐含地理解了一种广泛的心理偏见。当受苦的人与我们有共同点时，我们都倾向于更同情他们的苦难。这还有另一部分。安德鲁之所以成功，是因为他没有要求布什总统做出重大的U型转弯。从他政府的最初开始，总统就一直对苏丹发生的事情感兴趣。总统下令的第一次总统审查就是关于苏丹政策的。现在，后来被称为达尔富尔种族灭绝的事件确实夺去了数十万人的生命。所以可能很难看到安德鲁的警告是有效的。然而，如果安德鲁没有采取行动，克里斯托弗说他相信事情会变得更糟。
I think the Bush administration did act, it didn't act very early, but it did act politically to put pressure on the conflict parties. And they did act, I think, as soon as could be probably expected on the humanitarian front, therefore saving lives through humanitarian action and probably preventing the conflict from being even more disastrous than would have been otherwise. I couldn't have done that alone, but President Bush did it, and I have to say I said in my book, I think he ended what could have been another Rwanda genocide. So in Andrew Nazios, we have a plain-spoken leader.
“我认为布什政府确实采取了行动，它没有很早采取行动，但它确实在政治上采取行动，对冲突各方施加压力。而且我认为，在人道主义方面，他们确实在可能预期的范围内尽快采取了行动，从而通过人道主义行动挽救了生命，并可能防止了冲突变得比原本更灾难性。”“我不可能独自做到这一点，但布什总统做到了，我必须说，我在我的书中说过，我认为他结束了可能成为另一场卢旺达种族灭绝的事件。”所以，在安德鲁·纳齐奥斯身上，我们有一位直言不讳的领导人。
He had the insider credentials to get others on board. And he didn't ask policymakers to do something that was greatly at odds with what they wanted to do anyway. Contrast that with the doomed prophet we heard about earlier. Cassandra spoken riddles. Prophetic riddles, but riddles nonetheless. Let the mob endlessly gorging on this clan. Raise a shriek over the sacrifice on which stones will fall in their turn." Unlike Andrew Natios, Cassandra wasn't an insider. As Emily Wilson says, of an unauthoritative person for somebody who's dismissed as other than that can make it possible
他有内部人士的资历来让其他人加入。而且他没有要求决策者做一些与他们无论如何都想做的事情大相径庭的事情。将此与我们之前听到的注定失败的先知进行对比。卡珊德拉用谜语说话。预言性的谜语，但毕竟是谜语。“让暴民无休止地吞噬这个家族。为祭品发出尖叫，石头将轮流落下。”与安德鲁·纳齐奥斯不同，卡珊德拉不是内部人士。正如艾米丽·威尔逊所说，对于一个没有权威的人，对于一个被视为他者的人，这使得
to dismiss even a very clear articulation of a scary truth. And Cassandra was too far ahead of everyone else. When she and the other children women are being captured as slaves, she doesn't explain that she is happy because she knows the Greeks are going to be killed. She can see into the future, but she doesn't take others along with her. killed. She can see into the future, but she doesn't take others along with her. There are lessons here for our own time. Kristoff says many modern Cassandra's forget its hard for most people to look far into the future. Leaders especially are often pulled in different directions. Paying attention to one risk means fewer resources for others. If you come in with a vague warning about
即使是对可怕真相的非常清晰的表达也可以被驳回。而且卡珊德拉比其他人领先太多。当她和其他孩子妇女被俘虏为奴隶时，她没有解释她很高兴，因为她知道希腊人会被杀死。她能看到未来，但她没有带其他人一起。她能看到未来，但她没有带其他人一起。这对我们自己的时代有教训。克里斯托弗说，许多现代卡珊德拉忘记了大多数人很难看得远。领导者尤其经常被拉向不同的方向。关注一个风险意味着其他风险的资源减少。如果你带着一个关于
a distant problem, you're going to get sidelined. Samantha Powell wrote in a book, a problem from hell, about the response from one administrator to the warning that was given that unless his telephones were ringing, he couldn't do anything. So even if he believed that what she was saying is right, he was so constrained by the lack of intense public clamoring in the beltway that comes support for acting that he
遥远问题的模糊警告进来，你会被边缘化。萨曼莎·鲍威尔（Samantha Powell）在一本书《来自地狱的问题》（A Problem from Hell）中写道，一位行政人员对所给出的警告的反应是，除非他的电话响个不停，否则他什么也做不了。所以即使他相信她说的是对的，他也受到华盛顿特区缺乏强烈的公众呼声的限制，而这种呼声是采取行动的支持，所以他
couldn't do something. Cassandra also asked the people she was trying to warn to stretch too far outside their comfort zone. Remember what Clitam Nestra is giving Agamemnon a lovely bath before she hacks him to death. Cassandra saw it coming. Look at this! Look! Keep the bull away from the heifer! But Agamemnon wasn't in a headspace where he could hear the warning. Kristoff says this happens with real-life Cassandra's and real-life policy makers. If leaders have to reject some foundational belief to act on a warning, there's a strong chance that they will simply ignore the warning. Quite often, what makes warnings so difficult to believe is they're politically inconvenience.
不能做点什么。卡珊德拉还要求她试图警告的人走出他们的舒适区太远。记住克吕泰涅斯特拉在把阿伽门农砍死之前给了他一个可爱的洗澡。卡珊德拉预见到了这一点。“看这个！看！让公牛远离小母牛！”但阿伽门农当时的心态无法听到这个警告。克里斯托弗说，这发生在现实生活中的卡珊德拉和现实生活中的决策者身上。如果领导者必须拒绝某种基础信念才能根据警告采取行动，他们很有可能只是忽略警告。通常，使警告如此难以相信的原因是它们在政治上不方便。
In fact, this is exactly what happened in the case of the Challenger Space Shuttle disaster. In fact, this is exactly what happened in the case of the Challenger Space Shuttle disaster. A scientific inquiry found that several engineers had had concerns about the safety of what came to be known as the O-rings on the shuttle. They told NASA managers to delay the launch, but the managers overruled the engineers, and the Challenger took off his plan. Like a troller's here looking very carefully at the situation. Obviously a major malfunction. We've painted a picture of warnings that is at odds with the way most of us think about them. In the conventional telling, someone raises an alarm and everyone jumps up and does something about it. In reality, warnings are likely to be heard when they're made by someone who's part of our in-group, when the warning is so imminent that nearly
事实上，这正是挑战者号航天飞机灾难中发生的情况。事实上，这正是挑战者号航天飞机灾难中发生的情况。一项科学调查发现，几名工程师对航天飞机上后来被称为O形环的安全问题表示担忧。他们告诉NASA管理人员推迟发射，但管理人员否决了工程师的意见，挑战者号按计划起飞。“飞行控制人员正在非常仔细地观察局势。显然发生了重大故障。”我们描绘的警告图景与我们大多数人对它们的看法不一致。在传统的说法中，有人发出警报，每个人都跳起来并对此采取行动。实际上，当警告由我们内群体中的某个人发出时，当警告如此迫在眉睫以至于几乎
everyone can see the danger, and when the solution doesn't require a radical shift in existing strategy. Unsurprisingly, this means that many warnings will go unheeded, and many Cassandra's will be dismissed. After the break, why you don't need Cassandra-like vision to predict what's to come. Psychologist Phil Tetlock tells us about the traits of super-frocasters. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantin. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantin. We're surrounded by people who tell us they know what's going to happen in the future. A lot of people have no idea that Trump is headed for a historic defeat.
每个人都能看到危险时，以及当解决方案不需要现有战略的根本转变时，警告才更有可能被听到。不出所料，这意味着许多警告将被忽视，许多卡珊德拉将被解雇。休息后，为什么你不需要卡珊德拉式的远见来预测未来。心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克（Phil Tetlock）告诉我们超级预测者的特质。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们周围的人告诉我们他们知道未来会发生什么。很多人不知道特朗普正走向历史性的失败。
Bearsters is fine! Don't move your money from there! That's just being silly! These predictions have a few things in common. The commentators have complete confidence in themselves. We as the audience love to hear them make a complicated world seem simple. And finally, no one ever pays a serious price for being wrong. Donald Trump wins the presidency. There's stirs in the bargain bin. Sold to rival JP Morgan Chase for just two dollars a share. Making predictions is hard, even for the so-called experts.
“贝尔斯登（Bearsters）很好！不要把你的钱从那里移走！那只是愚蠢！”这些预测有一些共同点。评论员对自己有完全的信心。我们作为观众喜欢听他们让复杂的世界看起来很简单。最后，没有人会因为错误而付出沉重的代价。唐纳德·特朗普赢得了总统职位。廉价商品区有骚动。以每股仅两美元的价格卖给了竞争对手摩根大通（JP Morgan Chase）。做出预测很难，即使是对所谓的专家来说。
Ironically, the people who are the best at forecasting the future tend to be ordinary people who happen to know a very important secret. Predicting the future isn't about being unusually smart or especially knowledgeable. It's about understanding the pitfalls in the way we think, and practicing better habits of mind. Phil Tattlach is a psychologist at the University of Pennsylvania. In his book, Super Forecasting, The Art and Science of Prediction, Phil explores how we can learn from these people to become better forecasters ourselves. Phil, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you very much.
讽刺的是，最擅长预测未来的人往往是普通人，他们恰好知道一个非常重要的秘密。预测未来并不是因为你特别聪明或知识渊博，而是要了解我们思维方式中的陷阱，并养成更好的思维习惯。菲尔·塔特洛克（Phil Tetlock）是宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家。在他的著作《超预测：预测的艺术与科学》中，菲尔探讨了我们如何向这些人学习，从而让自己成为更好的预测者。菲尔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。非常感谢。
So Phil, lots of people watch television at night and millions of people feel like throwing things at their television set each evening as they listen to pundits and prognosticators explain the day's news and predict what's going to happen next. Of all the people in the country, you probably have more cause than most to hurl your coffee cup at the television set, because starting in 1984, you conducted a study that analyzed the predictions of experts in various fields.
那么菲尔，很多人晚上看电视，每晚都有数百万人听着专家和预言家解释当天的新闻并预测接下来会发生什么时，都想把东西扔向电视机。在全国所有人中，你可能比大多数人更有理由把咖啡杯扔向电视机，因为从1984年开始，你进行了一项研究，分析了各领域专家的预测。
What did you find? Well, we found that pandits didn't know as much about the future as they thought they did. But it might be useful before we start throwing things at the poor pundits on the on the TV screen to consider their predicament. They're under pressure to say something interesting. So they resort to interesting linguistic gambits. They say things like, well, I think there's a distinct possibility that Putin's next move will be on a stonium.
你发现了什么？嗯，我们发现专家们对未来的了解并不像他们自认为的那样多。但在我们开始向电视屏幕上可怜的专家扔东西之前，考虑一下他们的困境可能是有用的。他们承受着必须说出有趣内容的压力，所以他们诉诸于有趣的语言策略。他们会说类似这样的话：“嗯，我认为普京的下一步行动很有可能是在爱沙尼亚。”
Now, that's a wonderful phrase distinct possibility. It's wonderfully elastic because if Putin does move into a stonium, they can say, hey, I told you there was a distinct possibility. It was going to do that. And if he doesn't, they can say, hey, I just said it was possible. So they're very well positioned. Now, if you play the game the way it really should be played, the forecasting game and you use actual probability. So you play it the
这是一个很棒的短语，“很有可能”。它非常灵活，因为如果普京真的进入了爱沙尼亚，他们可以说：“嘿，我告诉过你，这很有可能发生。”如果他没有这样做，他们可以说：“嘿，我只是说这有可能。”所以他们处于非常有利的位置。现在，如果你按照真正应该玩的方式来玩预测游戏，并使用实际的概率，那么你玩的方式……
way Nate Silver plays it and you wind up with, say, a 70% probability that Hillary will win the election a few days before the election in November 16, you're much more subject to embarrassment. If he said there's a distinct possibility that Hillary will win, he could he would have been very safely covered. Because when you ask people to translate distinct possibility of the numbers, it means anything from about 20% to about 80%. The truth is making predictions is difficult, but many biases also get in the way of making accurate forecasts. difficult. But many biases also get in the way of making accurate forecasts. When we make a prediction and it turns out wrong, most of us don't remember that we predicted something different. In fact, the hindsight bias prompts us to believe we'd gotten it right all along. We also hailed people who make predictions that turn out right, whether in this talk market
就像内特·西尔弗（Nate Silver）那样，在11月16日选举前几天，你最终得出希拉里赢得选举的概率为70%，那么你更容易感到尴尬。如果他说希拉里“很有可能”获胜，他就能非常安全地规避风险。因为当你要求人们将“很有可能”转化为数字时，它意味着从20%到80%之间的任何数值。事实是，做出预测很困难，但许多偏见也会阻碍我们做出准确的预测。当我们做出预测但结果错误时，我们大多数人并不记得自己曾预测过不同的结果。事实上，后见之明偏见促使我们相信自己一直都是对的。我们也赞美那些预测正确的人，无论是在股市、政治还是体育领域，但这让我们无法看到运气的作用。许多得到正确答案的人只是运气好，而一些得到错误答案的人只是运气不好。随着时间的推移，概率定律意味着运气只能带你走这么远。检查一个人的预测成功是出于技能还是运气，一个可靠的方法是让他们做出大量的预测，看看随着时间的推移结果如何。几年前，联邦政府发起了这样一项实验。他们举办了一场预测锦标赛，成千上万的人登录电脑，
or politics or sports, but that keeps us from seeing the role of luck. Many people who get the right answer are just lucky, and some people who get wrong are just unlucky. Over time, the laws of probability mean luck can only take you so far. One reliable way to check if someone's success at predictions is driven by skill or by luck is to have them make lots of predictions and see how they turn out over time. A few years ago, the federal government launched such an experiment. They conducted a forecasting tournament where thousands of people logged into computers
做出成千上万的预测。随着时间的推移，可以检查预测的准确性。我们是五个竞争团队之一，旨在汇集最佳方法，对国家安全专业人员关心的事件进行概率估计。他们问的是什么样的问题？简直是五花八门。所以会有关于暴力冲突的问题，
to make thousands of predictions. As time passed, the forecast could be checked for accuracy. We were one of five academic research teams that were competing to pull together the best methods of making probability estimates of events that national security professionals cared about. What kind of questions were they asking? All over the map, quite literally. So there would be questions about violent clashes
在东海或南海。会有关于叙利亚内战、俄乌关系、伊朗核计划、哥伦比亚毒贩的问题，简直是五花八门。如果你被要求挑选一个人来回答关于外交事务的难题，你可能会求助于一位受过牛津教育的公共知识分子，他为一份非常重要的报纸撰写专栏。
in the east or south China Sea. There would be questions about the Syrian Civil War, about Russian-Ukrainian relations, about the Iranian nuclear program, Columbia Narco-Trafikers, literally all over the map. If you were asked to pick someone to answer a difficult question about foreign affairs, you might turn to an Oxford-educated public intellectual who writes a column for a very important
你可能不会求助于内布拉斯加州一位把时间花在观鸟上的退休人员。但菲尔·塔特洛克说，也许你应该这样做。他与汤姆·弗里德曼（Tom Friedman）截然相反。汤姆·弗里德曼当然是一位杰出的《纽约时报》专栏作家，以他的解释而闻名，但没人知道他的预测能力有多好。而比尔·弗拉克（Bill Flack）是一位匿名的、退休的灌溉专家，住在内布拉斯加州，在公共图书馆或家里工作，在情报界的预测锦标赛中，他在进行概率估计方面做得非常出色。
newspaper. You probably wouldn't turn to a retiree in Nebraska who spends his time bird-watching. But Filtaet Locke says, maybe you should. He was the opposite of Tom Friedman. Tom Friedman, of course, being an eminent New York time columnist, well-known for his explanations, but nobody has any idea how good a forecastry is. And Bill Flack is an anonymous, retired irrigation specialist working in Nebraska, working out of the public library or out of his home, and doing a fabulous job making probability estimates in intelligence, community forecasting tournament.
像比尔·弗拉克这样的“超预测者”有一些共同点。告诉我他们拥有的哲学类型，以及你在许多这些超预测者身上发现的共同思维方式。我会说，超预测者最独特的属性是他们的好奇心和尝试新想法的意愿。当我提到“想法”时，我是指“预测是一项可以培养且值得培养的技能”这一理念。因为无论你多么聪明，或者多么知识渊博，
Superforkasters like Bill Flack turn out to have some things in common. Tell me about the kinds of philosophies they have and the kinds of thinking styles that you seem to find in common among many of these super forecasters. I would say the most distinctive attribute of the super forecasters is their curiosity and their willingness to give the idea a try. And when I say the idea, I mean the idea that forecasting is a skill that can be cultivated and is worth cultivating. Because it doesn't matter how intelligent you are, or how knowledgeable you are,
如果你认为在这些任务上取得进步基本上是不可能的，你就永远不会尝试，也就永远不会发生。就是这么简单。超预测者倾向于以一种非常特殊的方式收集信息并更新他们的信念。菲尔·塔特洛克提到了对冲基金AQR的首席风险官亚伦·布朗（Aaron Brown）。在成为金融界的大人物之前，他是扑克世界的大人物。他是一位世界级的扑克玩家。我们引用他的话说，你可以分辨出世界级扑克玩家和天才业余爱好者之间的区别，因为世界级玩家
if you believe that it's essentially impossible to get better at these kinds of tasks, you're never going to try and it's never going to happen. It's as simple as that. SuperForkasts tend to gather information and update their beliefs in a very particular way. Filthat Lock points to Aaron Brown, the chief risk officer of the Hedge Fund AQR. Before he was a big shot in finance, he was a big shot in the world of poker. He was a world-class poker player. And we quote him as saying that you can tell the difference between a world-class poker player and a talented amateur, because the world class player
知道60/40的赌注和40/60的赌注之间的区别。他停顿了一下说：“哦，也许是55/45，45/55。”区分更多程度的“也许”是一项重要的技能。为什么呢？嗯，最优秀的预测者校准得非常好。所以当他们说事件发生的可能性为80%时，这些事件大约有80%的时间会发生。当他们说事情发生的可能性为90%时，它们大约有90%的时间会发生。
knows the difference between a 60, 40 bet and a 40, 60 bet. And he pauses and says, oh, maybe like 55, 45, 45, 55. The distinguishing more degrees of maybe is an important skill. Why is that? Well, the very best forecasters are well calibrated. So when they say events are 80% likely, those events happen about 80% of the time. When they say things are 90% likely, they happen about 90% of
所以你更新预测的频率是有区别的。如果你不经常更新你的预测，你就会与事件脱节。这意味着通常需要进行相对较小的调整。你建议预测者应该做一些看起来不太直观的事情。你不是看个案的细节，而是说预测者应该缩小视角，弄清楚某事在历史上发生的频率。
the time. So it makes a difference how frequently you update your forecasters. If you don't update your forecasters reasonably frequently, you're going to fall out of phase with events. And that means often making adjustments that are relatively small. You suggest that forecasters should do something that doesn't seem to be very intuitive. Instead of looking at the particulars of an individual case, you say forecasters should zoom out and figure out how often something has happened historically.
丹尼尔·卡尼曼（Daniel Kahneman）可能是过去一百年中最伟大的心理学家之一，他称之为“外部视角”。他说，人们在做预测时很少采取外部视角。他们通常从内部开始，然后向外推，但作为预测者，从外部视角开始并向内推有很大的优势。再举个例子。假设你在参加婚礼，坐在一个品味很差的人旁边，
So Daniel Connamen is probably one of the greatest psychologists of the last hundred years, and he calls that the outside view. He says, people rarely take the outside view when they do forecasting. They normally start from the inside and they work out, but there's a big advantage to you as a forecaster from starting with the outside view and working in. Take another example. Let's say you're at a wedding and you're sitting next to somebody who has the bad taste and working in. Take another example. Let's say you're at a wedding and you're sitting next to somebody
他问你：“你认为这对夫妇保持婚姻的可能性有多大？”你看着那个人，这很没礼貌，但你看到这对夫妇是多么幸福，这是一个欢乐的场合。你说：“我无法想象这些如此幸福的人会离婚。我想他们离婚的可能性也许只有5%。”现在，如果你问一个超预测者这个问题，他们会说：“嗯，让我们看看这对夫妇的社会人口统计学特征。让我们看看，在这个社会人口群体中，离婚的基本比率是多少？假设未来10年是35%或40%。好吧，我认为未来10年离婚的可能性大约是40%。”现在，这并不是预测过程的终点。
who has the bad taste to ask you, how likely do you think it is this couple is going to stay married? And you look at the person, it's bad taste and all that. You see how happy the couple is and you can see it's a joyous occasion. You say, I can't imagine these people
这仅仅是个开始。然而，以这种方式（从外部开始并向内推）做的真正价值在于，它让你立刻处于合理性的范围内。40%是一个比5%合理得多的数字。现在，你可以开始调整40%这个数字。如果你发现关于这对夫妇的事情表明他们确实有着深厚的感情，他们认识很长时间了，他们真的非常了解对方，并且为彼此做了很多伟大的事情，你会降低你的概率。如果你发现丈夫是一个反社会的风流浪子，你会提高概率。这些是“内部视角”的数据，会促使你进行调整。或者你可能只是看到他们吵了一小架，然后说：“好吧，我要从40%调整到41%。”这就是超预测者有趣的地方之一，他们会根据相对较小的事件进行大量的更新。而且大多数时候，大多数新闻都是统计学家所说的“低诊断性”新闻。
who are so happy together getting divorced. I think maybe a 5% chance they're going to get divorced. Now, if you'd ask that question of a super forecaster, they'd say, well, what's the, let's look at the sociodemographics of the couple. And let's see, what's the base rate of divorce within this sociodemographic group? Let's say it's 35 or 40% over the next 10 years. Okay, I think it's about a 40% chance to get divorced in the next 10 years. Now, that's not the end of the forecasting process.
它不会戏剧性地改变事情，但确实会改变一点点。理解新闻如何逐渐积累并导向一个结论或另一个结论是一项非常有价值的技能。我想知道，我们许多人从内部视角而不是外部视角开始的一个原因，是否仅仅是在情感层面上，我们的思维方式就是这样。你看到一对夫妇，你设身处地为他们着想，试图想象他们的生活中发生了什么。我们用故事来思考，我们想象那对夫妇的生活一定是什么样的，我们试图看看那个故事会如何发展，我们试图跟随叙事走向，而不是进行这种更抽象、更遥远的过程，即“让我从某事发生的频率的粗略估计开始”。在某种程度上，这是否要求我们跳出我们经常用来理解世界的叙事框架？我认为是对的。我们很容易被故事所诱惑。另一个例子可能是，假设我问你，未来10年内，
That's just the beginning. The real value, though, of doing it this way, of starting from the outside and working in, is it puts you in the ballpark of plausibility right away. 40% is a much more plausible number than 5%. Now, then you could start adjusting the 40%. So if you discover things about the couple that suggest they really are deeply bonded to each other and they've known each other a long time and they really
北美发生洪水并导致超过一千人死亡的可能性有多大，并让你对此做出估计。假设我让另一个人做出估计：“加利福尼亚发生洪水，原因是地震导致大坝破裂，导致大量水流出的可能性有多大？”现在，当我把这两个问题放在一起时，很明显，由于任何原因在北美任何地方发生的洪水，肯定比加利福尼亚因地震导致大坝破裂而发生的洪水更有可能。
understand each other and they've done great things for each other, you're going to lower your probability. If you discovered that the husband is a sociopathic philanderer, you're going to raise the probability. Those are inside view sorts of pieces of data that would cause you to adjust. Or you might just see that having a small fight and say, well, okay, I'm going to move from 40 to 41 percent. And that's one of the interesting things of a super forecast is they do a lot of updating and response to relatively small events. And most of the news, most of the time, is what statisticians would call low diagnosticity news.
加利福尼亚的事件显然是更广泛的北美洪水事件的一个子集。但人们并不这么看。加利福尼亚地震大坝的故事更像是一个故事。它就像一个故事。你实际上可以以一种更有意义的方式将其组合在一起，而北美任何地方的洪水则显得有些抽象和模糊。所以人们可以把自己带入那个世界，
It doesn't change things dramatically, but it does change things a little bit. And appreciating how the news gradually builds up toward one conclusion or another is a very valuable skill. I'm wondering if one reason many of us start with the inside view rather than the outside view is that just at an emotional level, that's how our minds think. You see a couple and you put yourself in the shoes of that couple and you try and imagine what's happening in their lives. We think in stories and we imagine what life must be like for that couple and we're trying
你可以想象它就像一部电影，就像一部好莱坞电影正在上演。他们可以看到它发生。是的，我可以看到它发生。这提高了概率，并搞砸了你的预测记录。所以再次强调，把预测看作是一项可以通过练习来提高的技能。当你做出预测时，从基本比率（外部视角）开始。警惕讲故事的风险。最后，业余爱好者做出三种预测：是、否和也许。
to see how that story will turn out and we're trying to follow the narrative where it leads rather than do this much more abstract remote process of saying, let me start with the rough estimate of how often something happens. Is something about that in some ways that requires us to step outside this narrative frame that we often use to understand the world? I think that's right. We're quite readily seduced by stories. Another example might be, let's say I ask you how likely is it that in the next 10 years
专业人士有许多程度的“也许”，并将具体的概率估计附加到他们的预测中，使他们能够回头学习自己在哪里出了错。但即使你做了所有这些事情，我问菲尔，你如何才能真正确定结果正确的预测是因为良好的技术。你知道，商学院里有一个老把戏，用来谈论运气的作用，他们把班级分成几对，说：“让每个人之间进行抛硬币，然后每对抛硬币的获胜者与另一个获胜者竞争，经过12轮后，有一个人被宣布为获胜者。”当然，那个人在商业意义上看起来可能非常出色，但实际上发生的一切只是他们碰巧连续赢了12次抛硬币。他们只是
there will be a flood in North America that kills more than a thousand people and ask you to make an estimate on that. Let's say I ask another person to make the estimate, how likely is it that there will be a flood in California that will be caused by an earthquake cracking a dam leading to a massive outflow of water. Now when I put the two questions together like that, it's pretty obvious that a flood anywhere in North America, due to any cause, has got to be more likely than a flood in California caused by an earthquake cracking a dam.
非常、非常幸运。你如何区分幸运的人和真正优秀的人？嗯，这确实是价值6.4万美元的问题。它在金融领域也会出现。我的意思是，它在金融领域也会出现。我的意思是，有一些金融教授会争辩说，真正著名的超级投资者，如沃伦·巴菲特或雷·达里奥之类的人，在某种意义上就像连续20次、30次或40次抛出正面的硬币。我们在金融市场上有很多人在竞争，他们在很长一段时间内做出了很多预测。所以你会期待一些连胜，当我们得到非常
The California event is obviously a subset of the more general North American flood thing. But people don't see it that way. The California earthquake dam story is more like a story. It's like a story. You can actually put it together in a more meaningful way, whereas a flood anywhere in North America is kind of abstract and vague. So people can transport themselves into the world,
连胜的表现时，我们宣布我们发现了一个天才。所以怀疑论者会说：“嗯，菲尔·塔特洛克在这里做的本质上是一样的事情。他是在给那些本质上很幸运的人加冕。”所以我们内置了很多统计检查，但你知道，你永远无法100%确定。对菲尔工作的另一个批评是，超预测者回答的问题并不是人们真正想知道答案的问题。我们大多数人对大问题感兴趣。美国和俄罗斯之间的僵局谁会赢？超预测者倾向于回答更狭窄的问题。
and you can imagine it's like a movie, like a Hollywood movie playing out. And they can see it happening. Yes, I can see that happening. And that pumps up the probability, and that screws up your forecasting track record. So again, think of forecasting as a skill that can be improved with practice. When you're making the prediction, start with the base rate, the outside in view. Beware of the risks of storytelling. Finally, amateurs make three kinds of predictions. Yes, no, and maybe.
俄罗斯会在未来18个月内入侵乌克兰吗？我认为这是对我们投入所有精力提高预测准确性的第一代预测锦标赛的一个非常公平的批评。我并不是说人们试图回答的问题是琐碎的，但我们能否让这些问题与深层的政策问题更相关？我认为答案是肯定的。我认为我们应该像关注答案的准确性一样，
Professionals have many gradations of maybe, and the attached specific probability estimates to their predictions, allowing them to go back and learn where they went wrong. But even if you do all these things, I asked Phil how you can be really sure that predictions that turn out correct are because of good technique. You know, there's an old trick that they play in business schools to talk about the role of luck where they divide the class into pairs and they say, you know, have a coin toss between each person and then the winner of each of those coin tosses competes against another winner and after 12 rounds there's one person who has declared the winner and of course that person in a business sense might seem to be extraordinarily good, but really all that's happened is that they've happened to win 12 coin tosses in a row. They've just
关注问题的深刻性。我要问你最后一个问题，这也是我认为对超预测的一个潜在批评，但它以我将要做的预测的形式出现。我认为我们许多人做出预测或寻找预言家和专家来做出预测的原因是，它让我们感觉自己掌握了未来。它给了我们一种安慰感。这就是为什么自由派喜欢看MSNBC上的专家，而保守派喜欢看福克斯上的专家。一种更谨慎的风格，即“你死于癌症的几率是65.3%”，这种估计违背了我们对确定性的强烈心理冲动，我们实际上希望有人能牵着我们的手告诉我们“你不会死”。我们不想要概率估计。我们实际上想要的是事情会如我们所愿发展的保证。所以这是我给你的最后一个问题。
been very, very lucky. How do you distinguish between people who are lucky and people who are actually very good? Well, that is indeed the $64,000 question. And it comes up in finance, too. I mean it comes up in finance too. I mean, there are some finance professors out there who would argue that the really famous super investors, Warren Buffett or Ray Dalio and people like that, are in some sense like coins that come up heads 20 or 30 or 40 times in a row. We have a lot of people competing in financial markets and they're making a lot of predictions over long stretches of time. So you're going to expect some streaks and when we get really
如果有人建议人们做一些违背他们对幸福和安慰的情感需求的事情，我预测这种建议，无论多么善意，无论多么准确，很可能不会被大多数人遵循。你对我的预测怎么看，菲尔？嗯，我认为你所说的话有很多真理。我会这样说。我会说，如果人们对自己所相信的事物所起的作用更诚实，他们会过得更好。我之所以相信这一点，是因为它能帮助我与朋友或老板相处，帮助我融入，帮助我对自己感觉良好，
streaky performance we declare we found a genius. So the skeptics would say, well, Phil Tetlock is doing essentially the same thing here. He's anointing people who are essentially lucky. So we built in a lot of statistical checks, but you know, you can never be 100% sure. One of the other critiques of Phil's work is that the kinds of questions that super forecasters are answering are not really the questions that people want answered. Most of us are interested in the big questions. Who is going to win the current standoff between the United States and Russia? Super forecasters tend to answer much more narrow questions.
还是我之所以相信这一点，是因为它确实是现有最佳证据的最佳综合？但你是对的，当人们坐在客厅里观看他们最喜欢的专家时，他们是在为自己的团队欢呼。这是另一种心理学。他们在玩一种不同的游戏。所以我只是说，如果你对自己正在玩什么游戏诚实，你会过得更好。
Is Russia going to invade Ukraine in the next 18 months? I think that's a very fair criticism of the first generation of forecasting tournaments that we put all of our effort into improving forecasting accuracy. Now I'm not going to say the questions that people were trying to answer were trivial, but could we have made the questions more relevant to deep policy questions? I think the answer is yes. I think we should be focusing as much
心理学家菲尔·塔特洛克是《超预测：预测的艺术与科学》的作者。菲尔，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯汀·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
on the insightfulness of the questions as the accuracy of the answers. I'm gonna ask you one final question, and this is also, I think, a potential critique of super forecasting, but it comes in the form of a forecast that I'm gonna make. The reason I think many of us make forecasts or look to prognosticators and pundits to make forecasts is that it gives us a feeling like we have a handle on the future. It gives us a sense of reassurance. And this is why liberals like to watch the
我们本周的无名英雄是索菲亚·道金斯（Sophia Dawkins）。索菲亚多年来一直在研究南苏丹的冲突。她耐心地帮助我们理解该地区复杂的历史，以准确把握其中的细微差别。有时，一个人对故事最重要的贡献就是把一些东西从故事中剔除。谢谢你，索菲亚。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请考虑提供经济捐助以帮助我们制作节目。你可以通过访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 来做到这一点。任何金额都非常有帮助，我们衷心感谢你的支持。
pundits on MSNBC and conservatives like to watch the pundits on Fox. A more cautious style that sort of says, the chance that you're going to die from cancer is 65.3%. These estimates run up against a very powerful psychological impulse we have for certainty that we actually want someone to hold our hand and tell us you're not going to die. We don't want the probability estimate. We want actually an assurance that things are going to turn out the way we hope. So here's my last question for you.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
If someone advises people to do something that runs against their emotional need for well-being and reassurance, I'm going to forecast that that advice, however well-intention, however accurate, is likely not going to be followed by most people. What do you make of my forecast, Phil? accurate is likely not going to be followed by most people. What do you make of my forecast film? Well, I think there's a lot of truth to what you say. I would say this. I would say people would be better off if they were more honest with themselves about the functions that they're believed serve. Do I believe this because it helps me get along with my friends or my boss, helps me fit in, helps me feel good about myself,
如果有人建议人们去做违背他们情感需求、无法提供幸福感和安全感的事情，我预测，无论这些建议出发点多么好、多么准确，大多数人很可能都不会听从。菲尔，你觉得我的预测如何？
or do I believe this because it really is the best synthesis of the best available evidence. But you're right, when people sit down in their living room and they're watching their favorite pundits, they're cheering for their team. It's a different kind of psychology. They're playing a different kind of game. So all I'm saying is you're better off
或者我之所以相信这一点，是因为它确实是对现有最佳证据的最佳综合。但你是对的，当人们坐在客厅里观看他们最喜欢的评论员节目时，他们是在为自己的阵营加油助威。这是另一种心理。他们在玩一种不同的游戏。所以我只是说，你最好
if you're honest with yourself about what game you're playing. Psychologist Phil Tatlock is the author of Super Forecasting, The Art and Science of Prediction. Phil, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor.
对自己正在玩什么游戏保持诚实。心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克是《超预测：预测的艺术与科学》一书的作者。菲尔，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》节目。不客气。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·黄、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。
Our unsung hero this week is Sophia Dawkins. Sophia has spent years studying the conflict in South Sudan. She patiently helped us understand the complicated history of the region to get the nuances right. Sometimes, the most important contribution someone can make to a story is to get things out of the story. Thank you, Sophia. If you like Hidden Brain, please consider making a financial contribution to help us make the show. You can do so by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. Any amount really helps and we truly appreciate your support.
我们本周的无名英雄是索菲亚·道金斯。索菲亚多年来一直致力于研究南苏丹的冲突。她耐心地帮助我们理解该地区复杂的历史，以确保我们准确把握其中的细微差别。有时，一个人对报道所能做出的最重要贡献，反而是删减掉报道中不必要的内容。谢谢你，索菲亚。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请考虑提供经济资助以帮助我们制作节目。你可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 进行捐助。任何金额都非常有帮助，我们衷心感谢你的支持。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。